you've accomplished some
incredible things in this space of
science
in the space of uh technology
space of theory and engineering do you
have advice
for somebody young an undergraduate
student somebody in high school
or anyone who just feels young
about life or about career about making
their way in this world
so i was thinking before that i believe
in emotion and
my thing is to be true to your
own emotion and that i think that if you
do that
you're doing well because it's a life
well spent
and you are going never tire because you
want to solve all these emotional notes
that have
always intrigued you from the beginning
and i really believe that you know
to to live live a meaningfully
creatively and here to live your
emotional life
so i really believe that whether you're
a scientist or an
artist even more but a scientist i think
of the marathon
as well if you are a human being so you
are really to live
fully your emotions and to the extent
possible sometimes emotions cannot be
overbearing and
my device is try to express them
more and more confident sometimes it's
hard but that you are going to be much
more fulfilled
than by suppressing them what about love
one of the big ones what role does that
play um it's
a bit uh a bigger part of emotions but
it's a
it's a scary thing right it's a it's a
lot of
vulnerability that comes with a love
but there is uh also so much you know
energy and power and uh
and um and love in all senses and in the
traditional sense
but also in in the sense of
a broader sense for uh for humanity
feeling this you know
compassion that you know makes us one
with you know other people and the
suffering all the people
i mean all of this is uh is a very scary
stuff
but he's really very very very very very
fabrical life well the the sad thing
is it really hurts to lose it yes
that's why you have all the ability that
comes with it yes that's the thing about
emotion is
it's up and down and uh the down seems
to come always
with up so but the up only comes with
the downs so
you